come into Starbucks and warm up with our  new ultimate fall latte it's the most  fall you can have in just one cup first  we brew our dark roast maple espresso  then we add pumpkin nutmeg and hazelnut  spice we then take that espresso and  pour it through holes and apple cider  donuts we made from scratch we then take  that liquid dump it into a pumpkin and  heat it up over a real brick fireplace  then we dunk an infinity scarf into that  and bring it out into a pair of brown  leather boots and it all goes into a cup  you thought we were done  Yeah right leaves [ __ ] you wanted this  you made us this way this is all your  fault  Starbucks new ultimate fall out  [Applause]